from the biggest questions of
consciousness
let's explore the pragmatic the
projections of those big Ideas into our
current world uh what do you think about
llms the recent rapid development of
large language models
of the AI world
of generative AI
how much of the hype is deserved and how
much is not
and people should definitely follow your
Twitter because you explore these
questions in the in a beautiful profound
and hilarious way at times no don't
follow my Twitter I already have too
many followers yeah at some point it's
going to be unpleasant I noticed that a
lot of people feel that it's totally
okay to punch up and uh
it's a very weird notion that you'll
feel that you haven't changed but your
account has grown and suddenly you have
a lot of people who casually abuse you
and I don't like that that I have to
block more than before and I don't like
this overall Vibe shift and right now
it's still somewhat okay so pretty much
okay so I can go to a place where people
work on stuff that I'm interested in and
there's a good chance that a few people
in the room know me so there's no
awkwardness but when I get to a point
where random strangers feel that they
have to have an opinion about me one way
or the other I don't think I would like
that and random strangers
because of your kind of out in their
mind elevated position yes so basically
whenever you uh are in any way prominent
or some kind of celebrity uh random
strangers will have to have an opinion
about you
yeah and they kind of forget that you're
human too I mean you notice this thing
yourself that the more popular you get
the higher the pressure becomes the the
more winds are blowing in your direction
from all sides and
um it's stressful right and it does have
a little bit of upside but it also has a
lot of downside I think it has a lot of
upside
at least for me currently at least
perhaps because of the podcast
because most people are really good and
people come up to me and they have loved
in their eyes and over a stretch of like
30 seconds you can hug it out and you
can just exchange a few words and you
you reinvigorate your love for Humanity
so that's an upside yes for a loner I'm
a look because otherwise you have to do
a lot of work to find such humans
and here you're like thrust into the
full Humanity the goodness of humanity
for the most part
of course
maybe it gets worse as you become more
prominent
I hope not
this is pretty awesome I have a couple
handful very close friends and I don't
have enough time for them and attention
for them as it is and I find this very
very regrettable and then there are so
many awesome interesting people that I
keep meeting and I would like to
integrate them in my life but I just
don't know how because
um
but there's only so much time and
attention and the older I get the harder
is to bond with new people in a deeper
yeah but can you enjoy I mean there's a
picture of you I think with Roger
Penrose and Eric Weinstein a few others
there are interesting figures
can't you just enjoy
random interesting humans very much for
a short amount of time I'm also I like
these people and I what I like is
intellectual stimulation and I'm very
grateful that I'm getting it can you not
be Melancholy or maybe I'm projecting I
hate goodbyes
can we just not hate goodbyes and just
enjoy the hello take it in take it in
person taking their ideas and then move
on through life I think it's totally
okay to be sad about goodbyes because
that indicates that there was something
that you're going to miss
okay
but it's painful
maybe that's one of the reasons I'm an
introvert is I hate goodbyes
but you have to say goodbye before you
say hello again
I know
but it it that that experience of loss
that many loss
maybe that's a little death Maybe
I don't know I think this Melancholy
feeling is just the other side of love
and I think they go hand in hand and
it's a beautiful thing
and I'm just being romantic about it at
the moment and I'm not no stranger to
Melancholy and sometimes it's difficult
to Bear to be alive sometimes it's just
painful to exist
but that there's Beauty in that pain too
that's what Melancholy feeling is it's
not negative like Melancholy doesn't
have to be negative
can also kill you
well
we all die eventually